let's take our next call we are taking
calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 who's on with me
next I this is a tunnel from Atlanta how
you doing what's on your mind today uh I
wanted to ask about well you know I've
heard you know the good thing news about
Ellison and uh Sanders is kinda shaping
them cry message going forward yeah but
I was wondering with how you think we
need to uh move Dems like Chuck Schumer
to the left you know so that we can
actually get real change yeah I mean I
think the best way to be moving
Democrats to the left is for making it
politically advantageous for them to
move to the left and that the the reason
for Democrats being moderate is in great
part not just because though that's
their beliefs although in part that is
the case but it's because being a
centrist Democrat in most districts is
seen as politically more advantageous
and more likely to lead to re-election I
mean certainly we've talked about term
limits also and if you take away the
incentive of having to position yourself
for re-election you're certainly more
free to just sort of be the the the
person that you truly are politically
and if we believe that Democrats are
sort of artificially centrist for
political reasons then term limits could
also help those are a couple ideas right
so do you think Ellison in Sanders being
there is is maybe enough to shape the
puppet like say for more populist
message you know it necessary and
sufficient conditions right i mean i
think that having people like keith
Ellison and Bernie Sanders more involved
in the Democratic Party is necessary to
moving the Democratic Party in the
correct direction whether it's
sufficient probably not i think more
needs to happen and that's sort of what
our progressive activism wing that we're
developing is going to be working on but
i think certainly ellison over howard
dean is absolutely a better track for
the for the DNC right do you agree yeah
definitely yep all right thank you so
much for the call really really
appreciate it